the right likes to say that they have a
claim on patriotism they have the
monopoly on respect for the military
they support the troops often by
supporting whatever mission the
president wants to send them on if it's
a Republican or by putting a yellow
ribbon on their car the right decides
what is disrespectful and they've
decided it's disrespectful to peacefully
protest at a football game by kneeling
during the national anthem and Donald
Trump has been all over this it's
disrespectful to the flag to kneel at a
football game it's disrespectful to the
military donald trump has now
disrespected the flag by his own
standards Trump was at a Pennsylvania
Air National Guard base being
interviewed by Fox News's Sean Hannity
and during the interview retreat started
playing which happens when there is an
American flag lowering ceremony this is
a time when you're supposed to according
to US flag code stand and cover your
heart and look towards the flag and what
did Trump do he sat there talking to
Sean Hannity notices the song is playing
in jokes maybe it's being played for him
or if it's being played for Sean
Hannity's great ratings on Fox News if
you're watching this clip you'll notice
that as soon as the song starts people
in the background all stand and start
saluting the flag but not Trump very
disrespectful isn't it take a look and
GDP now I have to tell you for the last
quarter three letters Reaper sent three
two and actually three two they adjusted
it upward what a nice sound that is are
they playing that for you or for me
they're playing that in honor of his
ratings did you see how good is
he's beating everyone I think they'll be
higher tonight I'm just guessing
so the fact is that we really were
really rocking we have 3.2 now this yes
kneeling is disrespecting the flag it's
disrespecting our military and Trump's
it's during the flag lowering ceremony
as everybody else stands and it goes
further if you believe in the concept of
Flag respect when retreat is played for
a flag lowering ceremony you're actually
supposed to stand if you understand the
level of hypocrisy I'm actually going to
show you the flag code called conductor
and hoisting lowering or passing a flag
which says very clearly during the
ceremony of hoisting or lowering the
flag or when the flag is passing in a
parade or in review all persons present
in uniform should render the military
salute members of the Armed Forces and
veterans who are present but not in
uniform may render the military salute
all other persons present should face
the flag and stand at attention with
their right hand over their hearts that
is very very clear and Donald Trump says
that sons of [ __ ] should be fired
from the NFL because they kneel even
though there's no actual code for what
NFL players were supposed to do during
the national anthem and then Trump
himself ignores the actual flag code I
could not actually care less about this
nonsense but it is by these people's own
standards that they do everything they
accuse others of doing wrong Hillary's
emails they're all using private email
drain the swamp Trump is filling the
swamp so much that it's overflowing
kneeling during the national anthem is
disrespectful to the flag
they sit during an actual moment when
the flag code tells us what to do and of
course the bigger issue is that the NFL
players did it in protest Trump is just
ignorant there was no message behind
what he said are they playing retreat
for me or for your ratings Shawn there
was no message there other than I'm a
[ __ ] being silent and not moving in the
world of Trump is more disrespectful
than joking about the music being played
during a flag lowering ceremony but
remember that
time when Obama saluted a service member
while holding a cup of coffee in his
hand that's really what's disrespectful
they've decided let's take a break david
pakman.com slash read it discuss any or
all of these topics with us we'll be
back after this